got this with kyle rittenhouse this one
actually really surprises me this is
from npr
prosecutors cannot call those shot by
kyle writtenhouse victims a judge has
ruled and he also ruled
they can call them arsonists riders and
looters
i didn't see this coming there's been a
few rulings in favor of kyle
writtenhouse in these pre-trial hearings
the trial i believe is what six days
november 1st it's supposed to start
november 1st any day now oh man jury
selection is coming up
i was saying before that i thought kyle
rittenhouse was going to get life in
prison right because the jury was is
going to be unwilling to go up against
the riots when those riots happened in
kenosha the only people who came out and
did anything
was for the most part written house and
the people with him the militia guys the
cops said thank you for being here and
gave them water
but do you think the jurors are happy
about that i'm sure they're just like i
wish there was no conflict now if they
side with rittenhouse and those
individuals maybe they can cross their
fingers that those people will come out
and defend their neighborhood after the
riots happen or they can say you just
he's guilty and he can go to jail and
then we don't have to worry about riots
at all this is going to be a very
important case because a lot of people
are betting on this case a lot of people
uh you know there's a lot of
implications to betting like in vegas a
lot of people are doubling down and
investing in this and a lot of people
are threatening to riot a lot of people
are threatening a lot of civil
disobedience a lot of people are
threatening to do violence to others if
this court decision doesn't go the way
that they want it to go so so you see
this politicized in in so many different
ways and that's why it's going it's
going to be so difficult to actually get
true justice here i believe uh because
of how many people from the outside are
involved in this how many people are
investing into this and what i mean by
betting i mean uh putting political
capital into this because a lot of this
hangs in the balance of where this kind
of where this country is going to go
that's how a lot of people see it and if
they see if kyle wins this is going to
be a plus for the right wingers if kyle
loses this is going to be good for the
left wingers and these are big sides
that are mounting a lot of power behind
this major court decision i think it's i
think that it's right he's a totem and i
mean i don't have a strong opinion on
the on the case i mean that's why we
have that's why we have an adversarial
criminal justice system i i the jury
should know more about it than i do
but i do think you know the the context
of the case
uh this sort of like mass
temporary collapse of civil society that
happened last summer is the context in
which this all became possible the
context which like a a teenager
justifiably or not was out patrolling
the street yeah weapon
like like something deeper has gone
wrong
that you get to that point regardless of
whether or not he was justified in the
individual shot where he said you said
temporary collapse well they aren't they
aren't currently okay they're not
they're not doing great in minneapolis
but they aren't currently having exactly
in kenosha they're having exactly the
same level of writing that they were
having i i think this is a symptom of
the greater problem which is the
collapse of civil society if you take a
look at the federal level politics if
you take a look at even state state
politics
it just it right now it just feels like
the law is
if
you are in line with the party in power
you're good if you're not you're out
democrats control most of the cultural
institutions basically all of them right
now they have congress and the executive
branch
and as much as conservatives might you
know people might claim the
conservatives have the supreme court
it's still kind of an establishment
conservative based on the supreme court
not a populist trump supporting one so
what happens well alec baldwin likely
will
you know face no charges cal rittenhouse
is facing very serious homicide charges
the crazy thing is
there's a lot of people that want to say
right now as a hero now i don't think we
need to say that i think the situation
was bad all around and people shouldn't
have been there but it's it's it's it's
hard to to discern exactly you know
how it should have went down i'm not
going to have all the answers but when
you have someone like destiny who is the
leftist streamer getting he got banned
from twitch's partner program for saying
definitively this was the clearest case
of self-defense he'd ever seen or
something that effect
like the fact that they charged him with
homicide in this very serious charges
says to me they're expecting to fail so
my my favorite example is did you follow
the case of the uh of the two
new york uh highly educated lawyers who
got picked up uh confirmation the
conflict matters
cocktails ramon yeah the guy the the two
people who went out and like threw
milestone cocktails and cop cars um
and what i what i love about that story
is the rallying to their defense like if
you go look at if you look at federal
records uh there were lots of people
that got picked up for arson charges
like uh guys who threw multiple
cocktails at the courthouse in seattle
uh people who bring their cop cars and
yet peculiarly these are the ones who
like got a full court press in the media
these these two highly educated
well-connected activist lawyers who
decided they would go out joy riding
with you know explosives and attack a
cop car
um handing them out weren't were they
giving them out to people yeah uh and
then well they and they and they
received and they received like
adulatory attention and all of the kind
of the the reason is because they know
the people who know the people who write
the coverage they are in the position of
power and so
they they eventually they they pled
guilty they're going to go to sentencing
i think they're not the statute of
action is 10 years not going to get 10
years they're not getting it nobody's
saturated there's major media
organizations running defense for them
yeah um i mean i mean this goes along
with what was happening last summer i
mean dozens of people were murdered
people were burned alive and then we had
people like kamala harris raising money
for them to get them bailed out of jail
right so that tells you that they found
in the minneapolis in the minneapolis
riots it was what like a month after a
building had burned to the ground they
found a corpse yep they didn't even know
he's the missing person they're like oh
the writers
yeah yeah the writers killed him the
murderer and
and you know it's it's what's what's
important about this is is not just the
like the the writing the writing happens
it's the normalization the cultural
normalization of rioting and
simultaneously the approbation for law
enforcement because you know those were
simultaneous phenomena is like there was
there was a collect
the real problem we were being told as
our cities were burning was that the
cops are too tough
would that be considered murder if you
if you burned a building down and
there's a person inside that you didn't
know he's in there of course but at the
same time a lot of people were unhappy
with the cops even on the even on the
right because of the lockdowns cops are
coming along shutting down small
mom-and-pop businesses people on the
right were like wait wait wait what is
this back to blue flag that i have here
that absolutely is is hypocritical for
me to have if i actually believe in
personal freedom and liberty i was i was
i was told coming in that i was gonna
have to be the one defending the cops
yes um
sorry yeah i mean you know i think i
think i think
look the responsibility the iran
maybe you don't want to eliminate that
particular topic now but but in general
it's not so the police is is preserved
civil order and of course the law is
written yeah and you know allow walmart
and costco to be open while they shut
down the small mom-and-pop businesses
yeah would you say that's ethical and
right and moral no i would not say
that's ethical or writing immoral i
would also say that the problem is not
with is not with policing as an
institution
well i think i think policing just in
general obeying orders from bureaucrats
when they're immoral illegal and decrees
is is a huge moral problem in this
country and why a lot of people on the
right didn't support them when black
lives matter stepped onto the streets
and were saying hey we don't like these
cops a lot of right-wingers secretly
they were like yeah yeah they got a
point i don't like them either because
of what they just did to me same
attitude of
uh
concern or or
opposition to civil society it's like
look at the end of the day we live in a
society that has rules you don't have to
like the real estate process for
changing these rules i think there's a
problem that this process has become
increasingly abstracted from uh
democratic accountability that's bad but
like at the end of the day if you like
the rules you still have to follow them
if you don't we don't decide anymore if
you actually we can't we can't live in
society where no
but we can't live in society where uh
you can be free to throw a molotov
cocktail of people and get free free
defense in the press and while i agree
that uh unequal fortune is bad and bad
rules are bad like the the ground trust
in that loan order i think is is
critical for running a stable
functioning policy and you're right
except when it comes to luke's examples
the police were shutting down businesses
by decree without legislative process so
these were cops who were saying look
it's not a law it's not democratic it's
not legal but the guy who signs my
checks told me to do it so i'm going to
do it anyway and they did it selectively
so the politicians friends got to do
whatever they wanted to the billionaires
take a look at de blasio painting black
lives matter in the street and then
sending 27 cops to defend that that was
an illegal seizure of taxpayer dollars
to do or or uh sure sure and you know i
think i think hypocrisy on the part of
executives and major problems throughout
the pandemic if it's if it's gavin
newsom dining at um
uh the french restaurant the laundry
right the french laundry yeah if it's uh
all the big city mayors who have been
caught not wearing masks or they
continue to impose mass mandates in
their cities it's a major pro uh
uh like bite administration officials
keep getting picked up not wearing masks
in public um on the amtrak
gary lightfoot and nancy pelosi getting
their hair did yeah and
there was a uh an incident in north
jersey where when they shut down all the
businesses a woman was doing a facebook
live stream showing off the things she
sold and cops came to her business and
said ma'am you need to close and she
goes are you talking about we are closed
and they're like no turn your phone off
that's the crazy thing there was no law
saying you couldn't post a video online
and say hey i got stuff you want to buy
it and the cops came and threatened her
who are these cops
these are the people so so this is the
problem i have
if this is the direction placing is
going where cops are quitting over
vaccine mandates they're refusing to
abide by the edicts and those who will
abide by the edict are staying in place
then we don't have what you described
police officers keeping civil society
you know functioning and enforcing the
rules
what we have are people who are not
enforcing the rules who are just acting
as lackeys for despots who are ruling by
decree in which case we need to stop
that now if abolishing the police is too
extreme and maybe it is then we need to
fire all the cops that are unwilling to
abide by the law and then hire cops who
are and how we do that maybe it's a
review process then but all of these
cops that are remaining right now need
to be questioned it's like hey we have
you on video shutting down a small
business by decree
we're firing you because of that or we
have a video of you beating a black man
in the street for no reason yeah you're
getting fired over that yeah so but i so
i think that's right you wanna you wanna
fire the guy who beats black me on the
street for no reason every cop that i
have talked to
says independent of the like merits of
the case like derek chevron was not the
guy that they want to be he's not they
they were not fans of his every cop that
i have spoken to um like he was he was
he he was doing something wrong um but i
think i think
policing in particular is so subject to
this like very particular um
uh critical lens where we like pick out
the most high salience harms uh do i
think that you know you you can go back
and forth about like the the validity of
public health edicts or their like the
the arbitrary way in which they were
enforced although i was gonna be forced
to arbitrary a little bit i think there
are lots of abuses but i don't think
that what i'm interested in defending is
like the institution of policing as such
because that's the thing that i think is
under attack i kind of disagree with you
because you know people throughout
history you know always argue we need to
do the legal thing well it was illegal
to segregate people based on their race
it was legal to put people in
extermination camps it was legal to do
all horrible atrocities that governments
have committed throughout human history
and it was written decree by the law by
executives by by you know whatever
processes and i think some of those have
to be questioned sometimes the law the
law right absolutely laws the law is the
least worst governance that we have
right it's it's it's just be it's it's
not good it's just better than the
absence thereof um
maybe i would i would argue that there
would be less harm i think as we were
discussing to bring the conversation
full circle the the thing that gave
birth to cover in house is what anarchy
looks like i think that that is
absolutely not that's a darker tyranny
no no no if it wasn't for the state
incentivizing putting fuel on that fire
making that fire that much worse working
hand in hand with the mainstream media
showing that george floyd footage over
and over again enraging people we would
have never happened if we didn't have so
many state elements participating cops
were there they were for that for for
days these people were burning down
buildings there's a video where a guy in
his 70s was his his mattress store i
think it was was being burned down and
when he tried stopping people someone
went behind him and cracked him over
this over the head with a rock left him
lying on the ground unconscious and
bleeding out and the police stood back
and did
nothing so why why am i going to support
these guys why am i going to pay for
these guys when kyle rittenhouse and his
crew showed up the cops said thank you
for being here and gave them water so
just one last point when it finally
reaches the point where they were
pushing a flaming dumpster towards a gas
station and they were we have video
footage and we've had three different we
have four no we had five witnesses so
many on this show telling us that's what
they were doing and the police did
nothing what do we do we can sit back
and say there was a good possibility the
gas station could have blown up
or kyle rittenhouse took a fire
extinguisher and put the fire out to the
trot they chased after him and then
someone fired around either into the air
or at him depending on who you ask the
press says in the air new york times
says that some witnesses we've spoken to
said it was at him and then he turned
and was attacked by rosenbaum and fired
in self-defense if the police were doing
their job this none of this would have
happened
yeah i agree with that
no okay so so you guys have michael
schellenberger on recently right yeah um
and and schellenberger in his book he
got what he claims is like the first at
length interview with carmen best who
was the uh she was two police in
seattle yeah um where where the the chas
chop protests happened um and she was
the one who got the order to give up the
fifth precinct and like retreat after
they took over the precinct and like
established their little autonomous zone
and when she says she was like this is
insane why are you telling me it's just
like very basic strategy you don't give
up a defended position to like a bunch
of
like rioters uh but she was ordered to
and i think i i think the reason for
that is that there was a sense that
police activity
and adver harmful police activity
manager justified was going to be
punished in the in the
public eye more than rioter activity was
so it's like when you go to the ice
cream shop and there's a little kid
screaming i want two scoops the mom's
like i'm sorry i'm sorry i'll give you
can you give me two more scoops he's
gonna he'll stop yelling if i do and
then he never stops yeah the police need
to come in and say
what you are doing is illegal right you
are hurting people and burning down
buildings and we will respond in
contrast but there's but there's no
there's a sense so so you talk about
you're talking about officers are
leaving over vaccine mandates um but you
know cops have been departing big city
departments uh either retiring or
resigning or most frequently as far as i
can tell going to other more friendly
jurisdictions and when you talk to them
what they say is basically like i don't
believe that the civilian leadership is
going to have my back i don't believe
that if i make the wrong call i think
they're going to throw me under the bus
because my job is not popular there's an
element of that but there's also a lot
of police officers that are brown-nosing
and are saying you want me to leave you
want me to give this police precinct to
these crazy people sure have it yeah
there's police officers standing by i
remember watching police officers
twiddle their thumbs as like rioters
were just taking
new york city by storm it's really
simple then it's really simple the
system's broken the police aren't
policing the system doesn't work the
institution as we've we've known it and
want to protect is gone
and so now my fear is what what remains
are cops who are unwilling to enforce
against rioters because of bad optics
and because they won't get protected but
they're more than hap they're more than
happy to arrest you for bearing arms
your constitutional right and they're
more than happy to
find people and do all of the
administrative and bureaucratic you know
civil violation stuff so all that's
going to happen is people are going to
say
i was going like five over and i got
pulled over dude give me a break some
dude burned down my favorite restaurant
last night y'all did nothing for it so
if we're getting only the worst of
policing and it's not just the police's
fault because of it it's it's you know
also civilian leadership then what are
we actually defending well but i think
but i think it's a policy choice right
it's not the case that you know it's
it's not the case that necessarily this
needs to be to be the arrangement i
think it's the case that uh you know
there there's when i was i told you
challenge book san francisco you know i
think one of the things that comes with
san francisco one of the things that
comes across is really
a theme of contemporary progressivism is
that
socially deviant harmful behavior should
be tolerated and socially normal
behavior the average person should be
highly regulated that like if you want
to
do drugs and camp out on the sidewalk
and poop there
you can do that and we will pay you to
do it but
you everybody has to be subject to the
mass mandate everybody has to have their
sort of it is sort of banned ooh diaper
mandate yeah
um
but i think you know i think i think
that that is that is a theory of urban
governance that's a progressive theory
of governance it's like and the the
things that happened in the riots is
that the judgment call was made that it
would be more harmful to the legitimacy
of the city to see cops stopping riots
than it would just be to like let
everything burn and this was this
propagates through the media right npr
published why writing is good uh
everybody everyone's a sense of luck in
defense of looting everybody was like
well the insurance companies will pay
out so it's fine you know that and they
didn't hosing the hosing the small
business owners in the process you know
there's a there's a systematic choice
that was made to say
uh this deviant behavior will be
tolerated because the legitimacy of the
system is in question if it isn't
tolerant so you know i
i take your point about the
selectiveness i just think the problem
is like several layers levels up from
the cops per se excuse me the problem is
like
terrible governance decisions thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you